it's a cold night in Paris and these
young children and their families are
spending it outside most people here are
asylum seekers who say they fled
violence and poverty for a better life
in Europe but few imagined that they'd
end up on the street relying on
charities for survival the six-year-old
girl is from Iran her aunt says they've
been homeless for months we have so many
problems we want to send her to school
but we can't as we don't have a home
these children and their mother who
didn't wish to be identified are from
the Democratic Republic of Congo I don't
know what to do
my children are 5 and 8 years old I want
them to go to school it's so painful for
me to see others go but mine live in the
street Amir is one of a group of
volunteers helping the families he
understands them better than most a
Kurdish refugee he arrived in France two
years ago as a teenager and was homeless
I was very rich my father has a factory
he has a mind my mom was a university
teacher she write two books like when I
come to here is I really shocked if you
come here you're stuck you cannot move
you cannot back in the north of the city
rows of tents and makeshift shelters are
crammed along the ring road campaigners
say that hundreds of children and
teenagers are sleeping on the streets of
Paris often in appalling conditions like
this and what activists say is that the
French government is flouting
international rules by failing to
protect minors under French law all
minors should be protected by the state
but if this charity's de Center staff
say many young people sleep outdoors for
months waiting for a judge to formally
recognize their age there are many
miners that are not recognized as such
so they are not benefiting from help
from the state and basically put back in
the street without any support after
more than a year a judge is finally
ruled that this Afghan teenager ahmed is
a minor now I become
I think good life in France to be there
up there I become good life the French
government says it wants to crack down
on illegal immigration and has tightened
its laws but the authorities tougher
approach seems to deny basic human
rights to some the most vulnerable
Natacha butler al jazeera Paris